Predicting how Spain
will line up at the euros in 60 seconds
Maratha will start at the nine
and Roger will play as a pivot,
but the rest of the team isn't so easy to predict,
especially the wingers.
While Una Simone is the current number one.
David Reyes move to Arsenal will make it a serious
conversation.
Will keep it how it is for now though.
Harvey Hall is a consistent starter at right back,
but Pedro Poro's performances
in the Premier League gives them a chance now.
The center back pairing will be between Pao Torres,
Laporte and Leonore Monde,
who's been starting a lot of the matches recently.
I think Laporte will be his partner.
Alejandro Balde is out injured,
but Grimaldo has to be a serious
contender for left back
even though he's playing as a wing back for Leverkusen.
I assume Marino will step in for Gavi,
and if Pedro keeps struggling for injury
we could also see Fabian restart for him.
Like I said though,
out wide is where it gets hard to protect.
I mean there's so many quality choices.
You have a Yarzabal,
Daniyelmo, Asencio,
Ferran, Torres,
Laminia, Malin,
William with Lumine
your mouth becoming one of the faces of Adidas
and Nico Williams
on the verge of a massive move this summer.
It would be very exciting to see those two start,
but I don't know if that will happen.
If you look at minutes played during qualifiers,
you might expect It to be Ferrant
Torres and Nico Williams,
but that's just because Danny
Olamo and his sensei were injured.
Forum is gonna be the biggest factor
going into the tournament,
but if everyone's fit,
I would predict Danny Olamo and his sensei to start.
But let me know what you think.